blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com pakman with
absolutely no hesitation or shame
whatsoever with no reservations at all
about what they were saying
fox news host maria bartoromo and former
trump economic adviser larry kudlow
suggested that joe biden might have such
serious dementia that he may not even
know where he is
he may not even know what he's signing
and that he may not even really be the
president that it
actually might be susan rice who is a
sort of
shadow president because joe biden is so
unaware of his surroundings almost like
a weekend at bernie's type
situation that they're suggesting now i
could say a lot of things in advance of
watching the clip
let's first look at the clip to orient
ourselves and then we'll talk about it
because it turns out president biden may
be
really given his first couple weeks the
most
left-wing president we've ever seen
national review editor rich lowry wrote
a great column on this
his actions on spending and taxing and
regulating on immigration and fossil
fuels
and other cultural issues he may be the
most left wing
i don't know whether he believes his
stuff i don't know whether he's an empty
vessel for the far left wing of his
party
but they are moving in the wrong
direction from day one
yeah well that's what i was going to ask
you who the heck is coming up with these
ideas
you know some people feel like susan
rice is running things does
does president biden understand what
he's signing into law here with these
executive orders
well that's a good question look i'm not
gonna i'm not gonna get into
you know is the alert or not alert he is
who he is
i knew joe biden very well a long time
ago but not for the last eight or ten
years
joe biden might be an empty vessel they
say who's coming up
with the things that biden is doing well
maybe it's susan rice who's a shadow
president running the show biden might
not even understand the things he's
signing
is joe biden even alert and that when
you talk about alert you know it's a
reference to this medical term that's
used
x3 when you observe a patient they're
oriented in three ways
to person place and time it's like the
most basic
medical observation you can make about
someone
as to whether they have even the
cognitive capacity to know where they
are
and when it is talking about is joe
biden
even alert so let's go through this in
pieces
when donald trump was president there
were such serious
questions about his cognitive state the
slurring the not realizing
people he's talking about are actually
right in front of him getting off air
force one and wandering off and having
to be brought back
by a secret service agent this sort of
glitching and and verbal
uh interruptions to his speech that were
very strange
um the talking about the oranges of an
investigation the citrus fruit of course
appearing to have no memory whatsoever
of things that happened shortly before
arguing with people combatively about
his cognitive state in bizarre ways and
numerous neurological and mental health
experts sounded the alarm about donald
trump
and we talked to some of them about it
and i would also ask those expert
experts when i would interview them
i would say what do you see with joe
biden because there are people on the
right talking about
joe biden dementia cognitive decline and
all of these experts said essentially
versions of the same thing which was
joe biden seems to have the type of
slowdown
that you see in more than 50 percent of
people when they approach
80 years old this is combining with joe
biden's
lifelong stutter to make him talk in a
particular way
but these not my opinion these experts
mental health and neurological experts
said they did not see the same things in
biden that they saw with trump that was
their opinion okay
having not personally examined trump nor
joe biden that was the opinion they came
away with
now i've been clear we shouldn't lie to
ourselves and others and say joe biden
is just
in joe biden in 2021 is just like he was
in 2012
when he ran circles around paul ryan in
the vice presidential debates if we were
to say that
it's obviously untrue and we lose
credibility 70 year old joe biden in
2012
um humiliated vice presidential
candidate paul ryan when romney
was running against barack obama joe
biden had a rapidity and a slickness and
a facility
when debating that he did not have in
2020 when debating donald trump there's
no question about it
this is common in people when they get
past the age of 75. now i'm
i'm not i'm not trying to be offensive
we have lots of folks in our audience in
their 70s and their 80s
even in their 90s i'm thinking of our
friend sam in cambridge
vibrant energized in his 90s and a big
supporter of the show
but if you think about this on a bell
curve at age 78
lots of people are not as energetic as
they were earlier in life
this is the reality of humanity so
having without question conceded that
does joe biden know what he's signing
is susan rice actually the president
behind the scenes
this is ridiculous to be proposing on a
national cable news channel
for maria bartoromo and larry kudlow to
be doing it's outrageous and absurd and
of course
you simply have to see joe biden answer
questions from the press
as he's done half a dozen times in the
two weeks he's been president
to understand he knows what he's signing
he knows what he wants to do about this
or that
he can talk in detail about pandemic
response and who's on his staff and so
on and so
so forth you only need to watch five
minutes of that to know
that he understands the things that are
going on at least politically because
that's what he's talking about so
they lost the election they tried to
then steal it
and that failed and now they're
resorting to this and by the way
most americans like the things that
biden has done so far you know kudlow's
saying this is the furthest left
president ever
well maybe on paper that's actually true
but he hasn't really done that much yet
uh he's reversed some of the things
trump did and gotten us back to where we
were with obama
but these extreme leftist tendencies of
biden that are being claimed
so far he's not actually acted on any of
them if they exist and
and for the most part the country is
relatively pleased with joe biden 63
approval uh in general of joe biden
much higher than trump ever got at any
point during his presidency
69 approval for joe biden's coronavirus
response so far
80 percent support for joe biden's
federal mass mandate and on
and on and on so not only does joe biden
know what he's doing
most of the country likes what joe biden
is doing so far so just
absolutely wacky irresponsible stuff
there
on fox news so this is starting to get
it's more than pathetic it's actually
starting to get annoying
republicans and even seemingly some
reporters
continue to try to shame joe biden
and really also his press secretary jenn
saki
under the guise of unity and
bipartisanship
into accepting a tiny package
from republicans on covet relief and
it just seems like groundhog's day at
this point
every day gensake is having to tell
reporters
no i don't want this tiny package from
republicans
she's rejecting the imposition of this
tiny package
every single day that she takes
questions so let's take it
a a look at some clips here here is jen
saki explaining the risk isn't a package
that's too big
the risk is that we do a package that's
too small going through
all the trouble of getting something
passed
and then it's too small that's the real
risk and we don't want that
it's an exchange of ideas an opportunity
to do that
this group obviously sent a letter uh
with some outlines some top lines of
their
concerns and their priorities and he's
happy to have a conversation with them
what this meeting is not is a form for
the president to make or accept an offer
so i think that's important uh to convey
to all of you
uh and his view it remains what uh was
stated in the statement last night but
also what he said on friday which is
that
the risk is not that it is uh too big
this package the risk
is that it is too small and that remains
his view and one he'll certainly express
today
then again a few days ago asked about
bipartisanship
why won't joe biden consider a smaller
package why won't she consider
a smaller package democratic leaders on
the hill appear to already be eyeing
reconciliation we heard
leader chuck schumer today saying that
they're moving ahead with or without
republicans
does this undermine your calls for
bipartisanship and are you urging them
to give this more time
well for we're all very close to this
here reconciliation and all the
terminology in washington
everybody who's watching may not be
reconciliation is a parliamentary
process it's a way to get legislation
through
it's a way to get relief to the american
people the president wants this to be a
bipartisan package
regardless of the mechanisms republicans
can still vote for a package
even it goes through if even if it goes
through with reconciliation there's no
blood oath anybody signs
this is another good point just because
democrats
might end up going through budget
reconciliation
to pass without to pass the coveted
relief bill
without initial republican support
republicans can still make the
call to vote for and what i mean by that
is republicans can demand a tiny tiny
package
as much as they want and jen sackey can
say i don't want the tiny package joe
biden doesn't want the tiny package
and eventually democrats might say it's
the 1.9 trillion dollar package
just because republicans opposed it
during the the discussion
doesn't mean that after the fact if
that's what they ultimately get to vote
on they can't say you know a lot of my
constituents actually
like this i am better off voting for the
larger package
rather than not because i might have
consequences with my constituents if i
vote against this thing
here's more from this week again about
the size of the package
jen saki is not willing to give any
signal
that joe biden will accept package size
reduction
and i'm glad she's being clear about it
two others on that you said in your
statement that the scale of what must be
done
is large that's bottom line is 618
billion dollars
considered large by the white house uh
well i think our statement last night
made clear that uh the president
believes that the risk
is not being too going too small but
going
uh going uh not big enough again
with the small packages what if it's too
big
the issue is it being too small and i
have to tell you in a sense
they're already democrats have already
decided instead of doing 2 000 more
dollars
they want to do 1400 more dollars which
would combine with the 600 from december
to total 2 000. that's already smaller
than what was promised by joe biden
right around the time of the georgia
elections they've already conceded
uh and i think that this is important
even coming to the table with 1400
instead of 2 000 per person
is already shrinkage for lack of a
better term in terms of the package size
here's another one from yesterday again
reporters
uh playing to republicans who say oh
it's too big is too much money
the president's bottom line is that this
is a package
the risk here as he has said many times
is not going too
too big it is going too small that
continues to be his belief and that's
why he can
he supports uh the efforts by senator
schumer leader schumer
and speaker pelosi to move this package
forward my sense
is that this is not going to stop
anytime soon so as i've said
yesterday pass the larger package
and do it with or without republicans if
republicans
really want to vote no let them say it's
bad
let them vote against and let them
explain to their constituents
why they didn't want to deliver a
package of this size
to them and then constituents can decide
does this person really have my best
interests in mind
and when it comes to the members of the
house of representatives in
under you know what is it at this point
we're talking about 22 months
insane right but in 22 months those
constituents can decide
to either re-elect or not their
representatives
who may reject the 1.9 trillion dollar
stimulus package i think that for
democrats this is very much a risk worth
taking
and i would like to see them just say
this is enough joe biden had the meeting
these 10 republicans are obsessed with
tiny packages and that's all they kept
proposing
gen saki rejected the advances of the
tiny package joe biden doesn't it's just
time guys
it's time they've already delayed and
they've already reduced the package size
i hate that this happened but democrats
have
already they sort of negotiated against
themselves and what i mean by that is
joe biden said i support and if ossif
and warnock win
we will immediately send out two
thousand dollar checks
uh it didn't happen immediately and
they're only talking about fourteen
hundred
that's the negotiation democrats as as
they often do
negotiating against themselves that's it
no further negotiation
let's move forward pass it via budget
reconciliation
we were there were questions about joe
manchin from the what i've read over the
last 24 hours
joe manchin is gonna go for it he will
vote for the package
uh so it's time to do it i would like to
see it done within 24 hours
i don't think that's going to happen
maybe 72 maybe 96
let's stop this nonsense let me know
your thoughts about it package size at
all
you can find me on twitter at d pacman
the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription is only
about eight bucks a month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
please don't forget and how could you
really that our program
is mostly funded by viewers and
listeners like you you can sign up for a
membership at joinpacman.com it does
come with perks including a daily
members only bonus show
there's the free show and then there's
the bonus show
every day weekday for our members
grab a membership at joinpakman.com use
the coupon code better21 if you please
to get yourself a massive discount off
of the cost
of a membership some interesting
discussions i spotted this morning on
the david pakman show subreddit now you
may or may not be participating in this
subreddit
uh we have nearly 30 000 of our viewers
and listeners subscribed to our
subreddit
this is free i'm selling you nothing you
can join the discussion
at davidpakman.com slash reddit
one interesting post points out that the
ceo of right wing social media platform
parlor
has been fired and this is a
wacky story the trials and tribulations
of parlor sound like they would make a
good
sort of like for uh limited run uh
dramatization
on netflix and a netflix original now
parlor which was briefly offline
after the riotous mob stormed the
capital
they now have fired their ceo john matzi
says he was removed as the chief
executive he didn't cite a reason
but apparently there has been a
significant
dispute within parlor as to how far they
are going to take their
so-called commitment to free speech and
open dialogue
and it's an absolute and total mess over
at parlor
a comedy of errors and who knows what
the future of that platform
holds um i did sign up the ceo this is
the guy who at one point said if any
prominent leftist with over a hundred
thousand twitter followers signs up
we'll give him 20 grand i said i would
take 20 grand sure i'm not going to turn
that down
signed up and repeatedly notified john
matsey that
i'm here and i'm i've got a hundred and
at the time hundred and twenty hundred
and thirty thousand twitter followers
let me know how you want to send me the
20k and shockingly
i never heard back also another post
from the david pakman show subreddit an
article about
canada listing the proud boys movement
as a terrorist group
indeed they are canada has announced
that
uh the proud boys and 12 other groups
are going to be designated as terrorist
organizations
some of these other groups we've
mentioned on the show before they
include these
a radical right groups uh like the adam
waffen division
and many others whose names are even
even more obscure
uh yeah canada is not messing around
here they are moving forward
powerfully and rapidly with getting some
of these groups listed as terrorist
groups now i
i lack uh enough of an understanding of
canadian law
to understand exactly what the legal
repercussions of this are but my
instinct is that the reason canada would
do this is not just
uh sociological but there that there are
law enforcement reasons to do this as
well
um in terms of prosecutorial discretion
or abilities when it comes to dealing
with such groups
although it would take a canadian legal
expert to tell me
more about it join the discussion at
davidpakman.com
reddit like i mentioned almost 30 000 of
our viewers and listeners
regularly participating on the david
pakman show subreddit there
are moderators so we don't allow
bullying we don't allow
doxing or any of that stuff so join the
party davidpakman.com
reddit this is just too perfect
donald trump's beleaguered impeachment
lawyers
have misspelled united states
in one of the early documents they put
together
for the impeachment defense of donald
trump
instead of saying the united states
they wrote the unites states uni
t-e-s unites unites
states these were the lawyers
this is so insane these were the lawyers
hired
monday i guess after trump's original
lawyers quit on sunday night
um they uh this was a document
a 14-page legal brief um
written to members of the united states
senate except
instead it was written to members of the
united states
senate um it also i mean listen it's
remember when uh i i can't believe this
is the timeline we're in but
remember when rudy giuliani um
uh farted i mean i don't know what i
could use a more
you know i could use another term but
when rudy giuliani farted three or four
times during one of those bogus voter
fraud hearings
and of course the fart was covered
extensively but
it was not just the style that was weird
about that event with rudy giuliani
regularly farting while speaking
it was also the substance the substance
of what rudy said as i previously
reported to you was just as disgusting
and in this case it's not just that the
14-page legal brief
refers to the united states is the
united states
it's also that it makes absurd legal
arguments the 14-page
document argues that impeaching a former
president is unconstitutional now what
you have to
there's there's so many reasons this is
ridiculous first
of all senators don't decide
about the constitutionality of things
in the united states this is a political
trial
okay and although arguably too many
senators are former lawyers and i've
are i've advocated for more diversity in
the types of folks
who are u.s senators and members of
congress
it is not up to the senate to determine
the constitutionality of things that's
number one so
a defense of trump based on the alleged
unconstitutionality of an after the
presidency impeachment
is unfortunately invalid at its base but
it doesn't matter because they can make
whatever argument
they want and the senate can accept or
reject the argument
but more importantly trump was not
impeached once he was no longer in
office
and even more importantly you can
impeach a president after they are out
of office
remember the trial is happening after
trump is out of office
but impeachment happens in the house of
representatives and
impeachment took place before january
20th when the house of representatives
impeached donald trump for a second time
donald trump was president of the united
states unless
time now functions in a in some other
way that i don't uh understand
but the senate has previously uh had
trials
on impeachment for officials who at that
point had already
left office so what's more embarrassing
in the end
that trump's own lawyers couldn't even
correctly spell
the name of the country in which these
proceedings are taking place
or the fact that they're making an
argument that is not only wrong but also
pathetic
and not up to the jurisdiction of the
senate take your pick
it's like uh it's like a choose your own
adventure
and um according to a report from axios
uh trump has actually started
to sort of privately concede
that a lot of the representation he's
had has been embarrassing to him
it's it reflects a certain amount of
self-awareness that we've not really
seen from donald trump during his
presidency but at this point who even
cares this is starting
on tuesday we'll be covering much of it
and if this is a sign
if united states is any indication of
how trump's legal team is going to
perform at next week's
impeachment trial it's going to be quite
a quite a scene to watch and we'll be
covering much of it it remi
when i read united states it reminded me
of god bless
the united sheish many of you i'm sure
remember that the israelis
and palestinians how does this even
happen
like doesn't spell check protect this
prevent this from happening like i'm
talking on a technical level how does it
actually happen
and um what one other thought i had as i
was reading this is
one of the big supposed selling points
about donald trump when he was running
for president
was that his best skill is hiring people
only the best people he's the he might
not know about
foreign policy he might not be an expert
on
uh you know what whatever anything uh
but he hires the best people and
i have a hard time thinking of someone
who has demonstrated themselves to be
worse at hiring people than donald trump
has been trump's best
hilariously or sadly trump's best
employee
might have been christopher krebs who
said the election was secure
and you really lost mr president and
trump fired that guy
the few people that by mere chance seem
to be reasonable people that trump has
hired
or allowed to work for him seem to be
the first ones that donald trump
fires and it is all a comedy of errors
uh
and we will be covering it we will be
covering much of next week's impeachment
trial live
on youtube twitch and facebook and i
hope that you will
join me we will also have continued
coverage of the united
states on our instagram page you can
find
us at davidpakmanshow on instagram and
follow me while you're there at
david.packman we'll take a quick break
and be back
with tom hartman right after this
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the number one funding source for the
david pakman show has been
and continues to be membership and
membership is not just a feel-good
thing you get access to the world famous
bonus show
every single day just for members as
well as commercial free
audio and video feeds of the show
day in and day out you can sign up for
membership
very very quickly at joinpackman.com
that's
join pakman.com
if the normal prices strike you as high
by
all means use the coupon code better21
all one word all lowercase become a
member today
welcome back to the david pakman show
it's great to welcome tom hartman back
to the program of course host of the
thom hartmann program
and author of the hidden history series
his latest book is the hidden history of
american oligarchy
reclaiming our democracy from the ruling
class
always great to have you on tom thanks
david it's great to be here with you
so let's um let's go back a little bit
as you always do in the books and talk
about the origins of some of these
issues that still plague
plague the country today how far back
does this sort of
uh oligarchical apparatus exist in the
history of the united states
well it goes back to uh arguably
you know plymouth rock and slightly
before um
but yeah because we fought a a
war you know the revolutionary war
against the oligarchy of the united
kingdom
it was called a monarchy but it's just
another version of oligarchy
um oligarchy being defined broadly as
rule by the rich
the consolidation of political power
into a small number of very wealthy
hands
it's sort of the political version of
what monopoly is in the economic
marketplace you know
and uh and then we you know we've had uh
this we're now in the midst of our third
real
internal challenge by oligarchs in the
era from the 1830s to the 1860s
largely as a result of the invention of
the cotton gin
the south consolidated massively
small farmers particularly cotton
farmers were wiped out
large plantations and their owners rose
up and took over the entire political
structure of the south
declared war on the north didn't like
that pesky democracy next door that was
you know agitating and rabble-rousing
among their ranks
and uh you know we we fought a bloody
war against these oligarchs and
and defeated them and in fact broke up
their plantations parchment is now a
state prison in louisiana robert e lee's
plantation one of the largest
is now arlington national cemetery etc
so then they rose up again in the 1880s
1890s with the industrial revolution a
new generation of oligarchs
and uh to the point that uh you know in
the 1930s in the early 1933
um they tried to hire smedley butler to
uh kidnap or assassinate franklin
roosevelt they
already had enlisted over a hundred
thousand uh right-wing
veterans out of this right-wing veterans
group to march on the white house and
seize him
um we overthrew that and and and
roosevelt openly said you know they hate
me and i welcome their hatred
he put the oligarchs back in the bottle
and they stayed there until the 1980s
reagan let them back out again along
with a little help from the supreme
court and today
you know we're now facing the third
major confrontation between oligarchy
and democracy and
and uh you know this study from gillins
and page suggests
that we are now in a full-blown
oligarchy and
the question facing america today is do
we continue going down that road
or do we go back to democracy because
oligarchies are very unstable
and oligarchs tend to oligarchies tend
to resolve themselves in one of two ways
either the oligarchs are defeated as we
did in the eighteen sixties
as we did in the 1930s or the oligarchs
turn
a nation into a police state as victor
orban has done in hungary or putin and
russia
uh in order to maintain their power
those are the choices we're facing right
now
when it comes to sometimes what you
might call the conventional wisdom
around oligarchy which is often not
it might be conventional but it's not
necessarily accurate there's this idea
that
the biggest acceleration in uh this
oligarchical
overclass so to speak was during
industrialization
in part because of the ability to really
concentrate wealth
among those who could own a lot of those
factories and take advantage of the
industrialization that was taking place
is it accurate to point that as the
biggest moment of acceleration of this
or would that not be right
well technological changes um
always have massive societal impacts i
mean you know you could
you can you can find that all the way
back to the agricultural revolution the
bronze age you know the iron age the
bronze age the
er you know the invention of steel um
etc
and and typically those kinds of changes
as the
as society gets reordered you you have a
class within society that succeeds in
grabbing as much of the pie as they can
um the uh the technological innovation
in the
in in the 1800s in the early 1800s was
the invention by eli whitney
the cotton gin you know the hardest part
of the the bottleneck in the production
of cotton is getting those
seeds out of a bowl of cotton they're
really hard to pull out
and the cotton gin could do what 50
enslaved people could do in the same
amount of time so the big plantations
which could afford the cotton gins were
able
you know they're 50 times more efficient
and that's how they wiped out their
small competitors
similarly in the in the late 1800s early
1900s
uh you saw people like carnegie and
rockefeller and
and uh the dupont family and and uh mr
dupont i forget his first
alfred dupont no it was alfred in any
case uh
you saw these guys doing essentially the
same thing monopolizing
you know the wealth and then converting
that uh
economic power into political power and
that's that's what we've seen the
billionaire class do now in the last 40
years in the united states
how do you apply this analysis to what
we've seen over the last year during
this pandemic where we've
seen when it comes to business we've
seen
very large businesses that already had
certain
degrees of infrastructure in place sweep
up even more market share
as a lot of small businesses mom and
pops and others for a variety of
different reasons have gone under likely
permanently in the cases of
of many of them well it's
it we're witnessing uh a
another reconsolidation this time in
part because
of the pandemic but also in large part
because
you know in 1983 ronald reagan stopped
enforcing the
the anti-trust laws in this country and
we haven't had a president since then
that
did enforce them so um you know if the
if
if the nfl said you know we're just not
going to enforce laws against people
punching each other in the gut as they
run by or ripping face mass off
pretty soon eventually you're going to
have you know the team that's the best
at punching people and ripping face
masks off is going to be the team that
that's winning all the games in the nfl
um that's what's happened here i mean
you know it might take a while before
you get there because everybody can you
know considers it kind of distasteful
but when reagan changed the rules of
business um he really set us up on this
trajectory to
where we're at right now you mentioned
the two ways that oligarchy can go
it can be defeated or it can become the
police states that you described
orban etc what tends to determine
whether it goes one way or the other
the people whether the p you know it
typically what
what precipitates the crisis that flips
oligarchy in one direction or the other
is is is usually an economic crisis
um and you know that's what russia is
facing right now with the
very very low oil prices which is what
their economy is
you know based on um uh with orbon it
was the
syrian refugees flooding into hungary
and his and and it produced both an
economic and
a and a social slash political crisis
and his
first the first thing that orban did uh
when he uh moved from being a president
to being an autocrat
was to say that he was going to build a
wall along the southern border of
hungary
to keep out the syrian refugees he
actually built that wall by the way
and uh you know and and it's amazing
there's a whole chapter in my book about
this how trump basically is following
was following orban's playbook blow by
blow by blow i mean it was just just
breathtaking and uh so
you know it's a crisis usually that
precipitates that
what is it that distinguishes an
oligarch from simply a billionaire
or a multi-multi-millionaire is it a
political power component is it
something about the political system in
which they operate
generally speaking i mean you know the
the definition is subject to popular
whim
because there are dictionary definitions
for an oligarch
um you know typically described as a
very wealthy person
um but but i think in the in this
context and certainly in the modern
context when we talk about oligarchs
whether we're talking about russian
oligarchs or american oligarchs or
whatever we're talking about people who
have amassed
great wealth and are using that for
not only increasing their own wealth but
seizing the political
power and process in a way that will
increase their own wealth and guarantee
the continuation of their wealth and
their political power
some might argue that the successes
against the oligarchy that we saw during
the new deal era
fdr you you mentioned that earlier in
your sort of kind of brief history of
the trajectory of this in the united
states
some might argue that a combination of
an additional many decades of
entrenchment of
power among the few in the united states
combined with the media apparatus that's
fomented by
high-speed internet and and the the sort
of fragmentation of media
make this a very different situation
from that in which
the successes during fdr and the new
deal era took place and so
it really needs to be a different road
map for achieving maybe a similar
outcome do you agree with that that
circumstances have changed to such a
degree that the playbook must be
different
to some degree or or not at all or
completely
what fdr did was uh he repudiated
the economic policies of warren harding
and calvin coolidge and and
herbert hoover those policies were
almost identical
to the ones that ronald reagan put into
place that were confronting right now
uh when herbert hoover ran for president
his two big sales pitches were number
one
uh a return to normalcy that was his
slogan what he meant by that was
dropping that top tax rate at 91 percent
that woodrow wilson had put in during
world war one
back down to 25 which he did and
his second one was more business and
government less government
business in other words privatize and
deregulate which was reagan's agenda
at which he did and that took us to the
great depression
the generation before that in the 1890s
the supply ciders so-called had this
theory called the horse and sparrow
theory
which was that because back then people
you know it didn't have cars they rode
horses
and the streets in in every town in
america were filled with
horse you know piles of horse manure and
um
and sparrows love to pick you know the
occasional bit of
undigested grain out of them and so the
theory was if you feed the horses more
oats
more undigested oats will come out the
back end which will feed the sparrows
in other words give the rich people
their tax cuts
and that will trickle down to the
average worker yeah sort of a farmhouse
uh a farmhouse trickle down yeah
recycled now three times in the last you
know what 180 years 160 years
what should the playbook be for the
people at this point in time
well what fdr did is he went back to
classic economics
adam smith economics and and in that
um you know he said that basically
what drives an economy is demand not
supply
and demand is aggregate demand is the
phrase economists use it's it's a fancy
word that really just means wages
so if we want to get our economy back in
order
what we need to do is get money into the
hands of average
people and uh to to a certain extent
that means
you know going back to to top tax
brackets
that are um substantial you know well
over 50 percent
and making sure that when people do work
they're
properly and appropriate appropriately
enumerated you know paid for that
so you've got the 15 minimum wage we
need to bring back labor unions
which pretty much nobody's talking about
right now but it really should be at the
top of the agenda
and strengthen workplace protections and
and worker protections right across the
board
and we need to strengthen the social
safety net we're the only developed
country in the world that doesn't
consider health care
right and offer basically free
healthcare to everybody we're the only
developed
we're the only developed country in the
world that has medical debt as a cause
of personal bankruptcy
we're the only developed country in the
world that has student debt anything
close to what we have
um every other developed country in the
world offers either free or very
inexpensive college
to to anybody who can qualify we don't
it's insane
you know we need to we need to go back
to the foundation
you know foundational economics this was
stuff that literally thomas jefferson
was pitching he started the first free
university in the united states the
university of virginia and was very
proud of the fact that it was completely
free he thought that would build america
he was right
it seems that one of the big propaganda
victories that the economic right i mean
going back to the time
maybe reagan forward when it comes to
the these uh
supply-side trickle-down ideas one of
the biggest propaganda victories they
they've had is pushing out
the understanding of the demand side of
economics completely and you see it even
when minimum wage is discussed you hear
the discussion of well that's going to
increase costs for the businesses and
they'll have to lay people off and they
won't be able to afford employees
it ignores which to some degree
ignores um that labor is only one
uh one input cost for the the product or
service that's being produced but it
also ignores the fact that
you're creating demand side stimulus and
all of a sudden all of those employees
have more money that they can spend at
other businesses it's it
it has been a huge victory to completely
make it a one-sided conversation has it
not
that's right and and uh yeah
you're absolutely right and and it's not
an accidental property propaganda
victory
right lewis powell laid this out in 1971
i documented in this book on american
oligarchy
and and then nixon the next year put him
on the supreme court where he proceeded
you know in a series of decisions to
cement these policies in place
um yeah but uh and and and and groups
like the heritage foundation
and the and the you know the funding of
universities around the country
uh university professors in economics
and political science and things like
that
uh think tanks that are publishing
constantly i mean
do any google search on pretty much
anything that has to do
that is peripheral to the interests of
the billionaire class and you'll find
just you know the first twenty links are
going to be right wing propaganda
it's it's really pretty breathtaking how
much money they've put into this how how
large a an infrastructure they have
built out since 1971
to promote this right-wing world view
that that really only benefits
the top one percent of americans when
we're thinking about
this nascent biden administration to to
what degree are you
optimistic if at all about uh joe biden
making good on
the promises he made specifically with
regard to this type of
wealth inequality and economic policy
that we're talking about
i'm very encouraged so far the biggest
challenge the biden is going to have is
the filibuster
and if joe manchin and kirsten cinema
continue to oppose eliminating the
filibuster
um you know we're screwed uh he'll get
one or two things done by reconciliation
and that'll be it you can only use
reconciliation once or in some cases
rare cases twice a year
and uh and and then the republicans will
you know mitch mcconnell will do what
he's been doing for the last
you know a couple of decades he'll just
block everything
and uh you know we've got you know this
is why people need to call 202 224
3121 which is the switchboard of the in
the united states senate and deliver
their
opinions their thoughts about whether
the filibuster should stay or go
to joe manchin kirsten cinema and every
other
democratic member of the senate that's
202-224-3121 if you didn't write that
down real fast
and and uh you know because we've got to
end the filibuster otherwise we're
screwed
uh we've been speaking with tom hartman
host of the thom hartmann program the
newest book
is the hidden history of american
oligarchy reclaiming our democracy from
the ruling class
we we will all be watching together tom
and i always appreciate your insights
thank you david it's a real pleasure and
an honor to be on your program thank you
for inviting me
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show is audience
supported media and you can contribute
any amount you want on patreon as little
as one dollar per month
plus you can get the daily bonus show
world famous at this point
and the daily commercial free tv show by
making those pledges
at patreon.com slash david pakman show
this is audience supported media we
depend on the support of our viewers and
listeners
whether you listen to the podcast watch
on youtube or watch us on tv
or even listen on the radio patreon.com
slash david pakman show
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
so this is absolute and total gold
we've been talking about how will
republicans defend or not defend
radical congresswoman marjorie taylor
green's various comments including about
a jewish space laser
starting wildfires when she harassed
teen activist david hogg on the streets
of washington dc
when she encouraged violence and even
posted to facebook
about the uh murder of democrats denying
911 denying
sandy hook and so on and so forth and so
far we saw
on yesterday's show we saw republican
congressman steve scalise
turn the question into an answer about
joe biden china and carbon so that's one
approach which is
just don't even answer the question
answer about something else attack joe
biden
we saw on yesterday's show republican
congresswoman nancy mace
did do a both sides thing which was to
say okay well
both sides have crazy people in them so
that's sort of like a what about
ism both sides type response trump brown
noser
and republican senator lindsey graham is
taking
a third approach which is to say
that the comments might have been taken
out of context
he barely seems able to even get the
names right of the various conspiracies
touted by marjorie taylor greene but he
says what about context
take a look at this that you have spent
some time with her
where do you come down on this idea
whether she should be stripped of
committee assignments
well rather me talking about what she
may have said i want to hear from her
so i flew down to georgia with her on
air force one had a very pleasant
experience with her
very very cordial very pleasant so
here's what i think she owes
herself quite frankly her constituents
in the country
is that true was she misquoted was she
taken out of context
i want to know does she still believe
that sandy hooks
was faked that 911 was an inside job
that
there's a jewish laser laser in the sky
starting
fires in california i don't know i know
how words can be twisted i know how you
can be taken out of context
but rather than me talking about her i
would like her to be
definitive i seriously love that does
she really
think a jewish space laser or laser
as lindsay says is starting wildfires
because you know her comments about a
jewish space laser
might lack some context within which
they'd be reasonable comments to make
we need the full context of when she
talked about a jewish space laser
what can you imagine that being the
defense
the only context that would be relevant
about what marjorie taylor greene
said about a jewish space laser would be
if she had said
what i am about to say is a joke right
before saying it
short of that what sort of context would
make a comment
like that about jewish space lasers even
remotely reasonable
and in terms of context much of this
stuff was on a post on facebook that's
the context the post
is the context and this is just another
form of republican gaslighting now
think of some other examples is there a
context that makes the statement
the moon landing was faked reasonable
i guess the context would be i'm about
to say something that's a joke like i
can't think of another context that
would make the statement
the moon landing was faked reasonable
vaccines cause
autism might be a totally reasonable
thing
if we had the context only yeah but the
only context would be
i'm about to say something that is
untrue maybe when she stalked
teen activist david hogg and it was
caught on video
maybe there was missing context there as
well i don't know
and while we're at it maybe there's
context that makes lindsey graham's
comment
less ridiculous although i can't really
think of what it would be now here's a
serious question
is it possible that republicans
like lindsay and others don't know what
context
means so when they say this was taken
out of context they actually don't
understand
the meaning of that is that a
possibility i mean we've had a lot of
times where
we'll be engaged in you know a
weeks-long or month-long discussion
uh with the discussion maybe is a bit of
a favorable term but
a disagreement with the right about
something and
after two months you'll realize oh my
goodness they don't even know what this
word means we're arguing about something
assuming both sides
understand the meaning of the words
we're using and this entire time they're
they're
using a word that they don't even
understand or they misunderstand
maybe lindsey graham doesn't know what
context means but in any case it's sort
of like a pick your own adventure
either marjorie taylor green misspoke
or it was posted by a staffer not really
marjorie taylor green
or maybe the video was deep faked or
maybe it was taken out of context
or she was telling a joke or she was on
a medication at that point in time like
just pick one whichever one makes you
feel better about what she said
pick your own adventure and go with it
and so far three different
uh responses to marjorie taylor green's
comments
let's now talk about the fourth response
there is a new war on christmas for
republicans
that's playing very heavily on fox news
and other right-wing media
and it is so-called cancel culture
now never mind the irony of people who
supposedly have been canceled and
silenced
regularly appearing on national
television like fox news to claim that
they no longer have a voice
i understand the irony of that and the
absurdity of that
let's put that aside for a second okay
we are now going to look at clips of the
fourth type of response we're seeing
to the outrageous and disgusting
comments made by republican
congresswoman marjorie taylor green so
let me catch you up
on the three types of responses we've
looked at so far
republican steve scalise went with
attack joe biden when asked about
marjorie taylor green we saw that
yesterday that's
response type number one republican
congresswoman nancy mace
said there are crazies on both sides
when asked about marjorie taylor greene
that's the second response a what about
ism type of thing
republican senator lindsey graham as we
just saw
said maybe the comments were taken out
of context which in this case
is a form of gaslighting that's the
third type of response
we saw from republicans and now response
type number four
is republican congressman jim jordan a
disgusting person by all accounts going
with
if we were to punish marjorie taylor
greene
it would be the cancel culture he
actually
says in this first clip from fox news
yesterday
think of the cancel culture let's watch
and listen
so there are many members of your own
party who are taking issue here
let's take a quick break and listen to
karl rove on this
very issue we'll get your response
congressman
if you believe that the jews control a
space laser that that starts fires in
northern california
and that there's some unnamed
high-ranking government official who's
got a heretofore unknown security
classification called
q and all the nutty things that flow
with that you should be taken off the
prestigious
house education labor committee and
confined to the dark recesses
of the of of the furthest building away
from the house floor
and then let the voters decide in the
next election she is a problem for our
party
congressman your response no one no
one's condoning the
remarks that she made i've not heard any
republicans say that those were
appropriate
so that's not the issue the issue is
once this starts tell me where it in
sandra
where does it who's next let me look
think of the canceled culture sandra i
said this on january 13th on the house
floor during debate
i told the democrats if you guys keep
going down this road keep attacking
people they're first amendment free
speech rights
where does it end it won't stop with
republicans it'll go it'll go to all of
us
and 13 days later what happened in in
california
dianne feinstein's elementary school's
name was taken off
so this will this will never end and if
we don't stop it now
everyone every single american's at risk
and that's what concerns me
so jim jordan a republican from the
party
of so-called personal responsibility is
saying there
if there are ever consequences to
people's speech
it's cancel culture and it's bad there
cannot be
consequences to speech per this
statement from jim jordan jim jordan
appears to believe
that free speech includes total immunity
from having your speech lead to
repercussions
and then jim jordan actually has the
audacity to say
in the middle of a global pandemic that
still killed 4 000 people yesterday
case is plummeting hopefully deaths will
soon but still killing 4 000 people a
day
jim jordan has the audacity the
testicular
fortitude to say that cancel culture is
the most dangerous thing happening in
the united states today
but you know what we have a first
amendment what i don't want is people
canceling everyone else that is the most
dangerous thing happening in our country
today
right now joe biden says during his
inauguration speech he wants to unify
well it's tough to unify when you're
impeaching a president who's already
left office it's tough to unify
when you're trying to cancel 75 million
people who voted for that guy
that is what's tough to do so i hope we
can get past this i hope we can get back
to embracing the bill of rights
now most people upon hearing that will
realize that nothing he's saying makes
any sense
but this idea that any consequence to
speech
is an infringement on the first
amendment is a really dangerous idea and
unfortunately there are lots of
americans
who watch fox news and think you can
learn about the first amendment by
watching fox news
and that's really scary because they end
up believing this stuff
imagine the most dangerous thing not the
virus
not the people who rioted at the capitol
on january 6th
not the dangers of allowing more and
more time to pass without passing
coveted relief
cancel culture by which he means
consequences for marjorie taylor green's
insane comments
that is the most dangerous thing facing
the country
replace the words cancel culture with
consequences and reinterpret this
consequences for disgusting speech
would be the most dangerous thing in the
country what
accountability is a slippery slope
according to jim jordan and in truth if
you know anything about jim jordan's
history
jim jordan's the last guy who should be
telling us what's dangerous
he has a history of overlooking real
danger and has been accused of failing
to report abuse
that was happening of college wrestlers
when he was assistant wrestling coach at
ohio
state i don't know if i'm supposed to
call it wrestling but i call it
wrestling
uh he's the last guy to tell us about
who should be telling
who who should be listing what is most
and least dangerous anyway
he's horrible jim jordan is sort of the
prototype
of the kooky american politician that
the world sees and wonders what the hell
is wrong
with the united states we have a
voicemail number that number is 2192
davidp
i got a lot of voicemails about this
recent uh bill maher segment take a
listen to this
hey dee um on the most recent episode of
bill maher's show like january 30th or
something like that
he had two evolutionary biologists on
that not only said that they were 90
sure that coronavirus started in the lab
but they looked a little bit confused at
why the rest of the world
doesn't think that i was wondering if
you had heard anything
about scientists thinking this i i
actually saw the segment and the two
evolutionary biologists that the caller
is referring to
are brett weinstein and uh i i think
it's his wife
uh heather heing haying i'm not sure how
to pronounce it
i did see the segment on bill maher and
they they made uh
statements to the to the tone of
they think it's quite plausible that um
the coronavirus
was uh made in a lab in china either on
and it could have been released or maybe
it got out
and um i you know i've exchanged a few
messages over the years with brett
weinstein i've invited him on the
program
before and he's never taken me up on it
uh to me those comments are not the ones
i look to when i try to
you know um i would go to a virologist
and other folks who specialize in
viruses
for opinions about uh whether there's
any reason to believe that kovid was
man-made and or released on purpose or
accidentally from
a chinese lab i don't know where
evolutionary biologists are are
getting the framework with which to say
things like what brett and heather
said and my view continues to be that of
what virologists are saying
which are and i'm summarizing here
while it has not been definitively
disproven
that kovid could have come from a lab
there is no
evidence at this point in time to
believe that that's the case
and that's my position right now and
everybody else can sort of judge for
themselves what they think are
reasonable or responsible comments to be
to be
be making about that i am not trying to
suppress anyone's speech
i don't think it's something that should
be uh you know
nobody should be barred from
investigating the origins of the virus
and
uh that's my understanding of uh the
consensus of virology
at this point in time we've got a great
bonus show for you today get instant
access by becoming a member
at joinpackman.com
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman